je vous demande de répondre oui
le oui à la vème république c'était il
ya 60 ans mais à quand la 6ème
république
aujourd'hui c'est le projet de jean luc
mélenchon trop de pouvoirs pour le
président pas assez aux mains du peuple
voilà pour l'essentiel des critiques
mais mélenchon n'est pas le premier à
s'attaquer à la 5e avant lui il y a eu
des politiques de tous bords et
particulièrement des socialistes et il
veut la république
le premier d'entre eux c'est françois
mitterrand en 1965 alors qu'il est
député
il reproche au président de gaulle
d'incarner le pouvoir à lui seul sans
grande concertation un régime
démocratique un régime plus l'armée de
métier alors nous n'en voulons pas le
pouvoir du président au détriment de
celui des députés
c'est ce qu'explique une grande figure
de la gauche pierre mendès-france
en 1978 le rôle du député devenu un rôle
d'intermédiaire de porte-parole
d'émissaires de bonne volonté
des années plus tard la nouvelle
génération s'empare de cette idée 1998
un jeune député tout juste élu plaide
pour plus de pouvoir aux parlementaires
c'est arnaud montebourg c'est bien
dommage que dans un système comme celui
là la base ne puisse pas faire remonter
son influence jusqu'en haut du sommet
arnaud montebourg fait de la sixième
république son cheval de bataille pour
la première fois en 2006
l'expression est lâchée même si son
parti ne partage pas forcément l'idée
c'est ce que nous voulons imaginer dans
la 6ème république et les pouvoirs du
président l'idée infuse au sein du ps et
devient un thème de la présidentielle de
la 6ème république c'est synonyme de
changement et de rupture débat d'entre
deux tours ségolène royal écoutez je
crois que les français sont fatigués de
la confrontation bloc contre bloc
je crois qu'ils en ont assez aussi
d'avoir des institutions qui ne leur
ressemblent pas et je ferai donc une
réforme profonde des institutions une
nouvelle république s'appellera sans
doute la 6ème république bon c'est
nicolas sarkozy qui a été élu président
enfin président
ses opposants préfère parler d'
hyperprésident nous avons un mal à mal
structurelles profondes vème république
je l'appelle toujours tel qu'il est
c'est la monocratie tous les pouvoirs
sont dans les mains du président de la
république
curieuse conception quand même de nos
institutions où c'est le président qui
pose des questions fait les réponses
organise les travaux de l'assemblée au
pouvoir à son tour françois hollande n'y
a absolument rien changé tout comme
mitterrand durant ses deux septennats
[Musique]